Hi everyone, it's Jerry. I have an instructive game to share with you from the 1988 USSR
Championship. On the white end, Garry Kasparov playing against Vasyl Ivanchuk. 24 move game,
out of an English. Very accurate game by Kasparov. With this one we have a nice instructive fight
over the center. To be a bit more exact, a nice fight over the e4 square. It's a Four Knights
English, kingside fianchetto for Kasparov, both sides castle, and Ivanchuk plays e4.
So when this move is played, one of the things Black is saying is, I'm prepared to give up my
bishop for the knight. He may have already been saying this with the bishop's initial deployment
to b4, but certainly here, playing e4, you have to be prepared to make this capture.
The reason being, if White plays knight g5, he does. The only way to not lose a pawn,
which is hit three times and only defended once, is to remove an attacker.
And next, Black will have to add a defender of e4. So that's what we have. Bishop takes knight.
Kasparov follows the general rule, taking towards the center. This opens the b-file.
Possible coordination now between the queen rook and king bishop on b7. Rook e8 to defend e4.
Now, if you had to, in this position, challenge e4 with a pawn, which one are you going with?
d3 or f3? Feel free to pause the video. Okay, in this game, it's f3. Computer doesn't care
either way. Holds it around the same, evaluation-wise. What would prompt a player to go
with f3 over d3? Well, notice Black's last move. It has left f7 a bit more sensitive. There's now
only one defender. There's one attacker. And maybe, now that f3 is in, a second attacker
might be there one day. Possible knight rook coordination? This is one way you can maybe
look at it. And another is to say, hey, I heard center pawns are a bit more valuable than flank
pawns. That's the exchange we get. Flank pawn for center pawn. Now, before I go any further,
I'd like to point out that you should not treat queen e7 and rook e8 in the same way
in this position. There is a big difference between these two moves now. If you go with f3,
you're already lost. Queen c5 check, and there goes your knight. Alright, in this game,
it's rook e8, challenged with the f-pawn. E takes f, knight takes f, and now we can
stare at this, a majority for white in the center. d5 is met with d4. The majority is
immediately set into motion for white in this position. He's not taking on d5. Why isn't he
maybe taking on d5? It helps black to develop a new piece. There isn't a wonderful discovery for
white. This may be a bit appealing to play in this way. Some knight move attacking the queen,
but she has options. There isn't a great follow-up for white in this position. In this one, it is
simply d4. The bishop is ready to play. The follow-up now, knight e4. Knight e4 is not just
about improving a piece, it's defensive in a way. Instead of knight to e4, if black takes on c4,
white can pin the knight. A bit of an irritating position now for black.
The pin could be resolved with h6, but this is a simple continuation. White can take on f6 and
then play in the center. Beautiful fourth rank duo. e4 is poison in this position. Knight d2 would
target the rook twice and queen once. White would be winning after rook takes e4 here.
Also note that white could be a pest, maintaining the pin. g5 to try and break it. There are
sacrifices on g5. It's avoided altogether. The knight improves and there is no pin.
c3 is under fire. It's defended. Only now does black take on c4, only after avoiding
the pin. So what can we say about this position? Black has just won a pawn.
Black has just captured away from the center. Black has weakened his control over e4.
Alright, from here, rook b1, and now the play is f5, increasing his control over e4.
Another approach for black, instead of f5, is to play queen e7. It seems,
how to describe it? It seems the more solid approach. It's not as weakening.
Why doesn't black maybe play in this way? Well, we have this interference move,
knight e5, and this is maybe a position black did not want to be in. One where the bishop arrives
on e4. We could see two targets now, the h7 pawn and b7 pawn. It's still an approach.
Calls it around even, this position, but maybe this is a reason for
f5 instead of queen to e7. The knight is now defended by a pawn. Knight e5 is not an option
in this position. What do you think Kasparov's next move is? Feel free to pause the video.
Okay, it is considered the best move, and that is g4. This is trying to pull away the flank pawn
from controlling the e4 square. Black does not bite on g4. In the game, it is queen e7.
How can play continue if black takes on g4? Knight e5. Knight takes knight, bishop takes
knight, and again, there are these two points that are under fire twice. Also, after knight e5,
if the knight returns to d6, one continuation for white is to take on c6.
You could take on c6 here. There's some compensation if we have bishop for rook exchange,
but it even likes this move here, e4. It really emphasizes this nice center for white. The e-pawn
already gets to roll. The e-pawn, by the way, is a passed pawn. Not a direction for black in this
position. No taking away from the center here. Instead, he strengthens his control of e4.
Now the capture on f5, and up until this point, very accurate play by both sides.
This position, though, for black, this is where he goes wrong. There's a blunder in this position.
The move played, knight d6. What is considered best is the capture on f5. Now, why does black
maybe not play in this way? What keeps black from capturing the f-pawn, possibly? I believe it may
have been knight g5, some ending where white ends up with a very active rook. I'm going to put on a
bunch of moves here that are really just all forcing moves, capturing moves. How does this
look? Bishop g6, here are the captures I'm referring to, where we get straight into an ending
and this rook is really active. What do you do to defend this pawn? You have to make a completely
defensive move, like rook to c8. Rook f2, if you try to reposition the knight, you give up control
of b4. There's rook b4 to c4. I would not at all be surprised if this is a reason why black did not
want to play bishop takes on f5, seeing an endgame position like this where you are tethered
to the defense of a pawn, where you have this very passive rook position, very active white
rook position. Alright in this game, it is knight d6. So what is black's intention? He has two points in mind,
f5, hit twice, and also e2, hit twice. White, however, has a winning continuation after this
move. I wonder if you can spot it. There's only one winning move. Feel free to pause the video.
Alright, in this game, it is knight g5. What's happening here? White's coordinating,
you might say, with his furthest advanced pawn. e6 is a hole. Both sides have a pawn planted
in the other's camp, f5 and c4, but the big difference between the two of these pawns
is this pawn controls a hole. No holes here. This is a big problem. Not only is there coordination
on e6, but the bishop has been unmasked. And who's stopping bishop d5? There's no stopping bishop
d5. That's going to hit. Then we're going to be looking at the bishop on d5 coordinating with the
knight on g5 on these squares, f7 and e6. Big problems here for black. There is no way out
at this stage. Also, f5 is defended twice because of this last move, so really a lot
is happening here. What black plays now, queen takes e2. The check is thrown in. The king goes
to the corner. If you try to go towards the center, you're really asking for trouble.
Knight check, the king is forced to e7, and now there's a disconnect between the majors.
Queen is a goner. Alright, in this game it is king h8. Now we have queen takes queen,
rook takes queen. Not too late to continue to develop, bishop f4. The rooks are connected,
and now there's ideas to take the knight, which is the key defender of f7,
and then jump into f7. What's black going to do about this? In the game, knight d8 is played
to defend f7. What other options does black have here? If black takes on f5,
here's one continuation that will net white some material. We get to see this check,
discovered check, and then knight takes knight, bishop takes pawn, and a piece will soon be won.
Another continuation, one that leads to a very nice mate,
is this one here. If black takes on f5 with the bishop, we can play bishop takes knight.
If pawn recaptures, rook takes bishop, white's up a piece. And if bishop takes rook, we would have
a mate in three. With knight f7 check, knight d8, discovered check, cutting off the rook from
defending f8, and now pick your favorite, rook e8, king h8, the only legal moves, both are met
with rook f8, mate. So, in this game, it is knight d8, in comes bishop takes knight.
At first glance, you may be saying, oh, white's removing a defender of c4 and is now going to
capture on c4 and attack the rook. This is a way forward for white, still considered winning,
but white has his eye on something more. There's a bigger prize here. There's a deficiency,
you might say, with this underdeveloping move. This guy is now that much further off
from being a contributor. It's not defending any of the kingside squares. It's no closer
to defending any of the kingside squares. This is white's opportunity to now take over control
of the only open file. Rook b to e1, rook exchange, and now black is facing a mate in one
threat. It's as simple as that. It's defended with bishop d7, but the rook can still enter on the
7th. Bishop c6, and we are one move out from black resigning. Can you spot the very best
move here? Final move? Feel free to pause the video. Okay, here we go. f6, and Ivanchuk resigns.
What's going on? Well, if you push the pawn, well, first of all, white is threatening mate.
Pawn takes pawn. It's over. What do you do about that? If you push the pawn or capture on f6,
that opens up the 7th rank. Rook takes h7, checkmate. What other options are there here
for black? Bishop takes bishop is really the only one to look at.
It's going to be a mate in three. With rook check, only move is to block.
f7, and now what do you do here? If you don't take on f7 with the knight,
pawn takes bishop, promoting to a queen or rook will be mate. And if you do take the pawn,
we would have the crowd favorite ending, knight takes knight, smothered mate.
What did you think of this one? Anyhow, feel free, as usual, to leave any feedback to this
video in the comments section below. I hope you enjoyed it
and maybe took a thing or two away. That's all for now. Take care. Bye.